[Música]
entonces
vengo aquí todos los años trato de pescar lo
mejor que puedo supongo que puedes decir pero
no siempre los atrapo sé que mi papá
siempre tiene suerte y tiende a llegar
a la tabla de clasificación de alguna manera o  otra cosa aparte de
eso, no, solo lo disfruto, me
encanta, es genial venir a ver
a los locos que
se destacan aquí, pasar un
buen rato con amigos
[Música],
es genial estar al aire libre en
enero en minnesota por la diversión de  eso
y sí,
solo estamos aquí para pasar un buen
rato, si tenemos suerte, atraparemos algunos
peces y, si no, lo pasaremos bien
estando al aire libre juntos
[Música]
es mi besito
[  Música]